one other aspect of this given a
difficult childhood whether it's Elon or
da Vinci
I wonder if there's some wisdom
some advice almost that you can draw
that you can give to people with
difficult childhoods I think all of us
have demons even those of us who grew up
in a magical part of New Orleans with
sweet parents yes and we all have demons
and
rule one in life is harness your demons
know that you're ambitious or not
ambitious or you're lazy or whatever
uh Leonardo da Vinci knew he was a
procrastinator you know I think
as usual to know what's eating at you
know how to harness it
um also know what you're good at I'll
take musk as another example
I'm a little bit more like Kimball musk
than Elon uh maybe got over endowed with
the empathy Gene and what does that mean
well it means that I was okay when I ran
Time Magazine it was a group about a 150
people on the editorial floors and I
knew them all and we had a jolly time
when I went to CNN I was not very good
at being a manager or an executive of an
organization
uh I cared a little bit too much that
people didn't get annoyed at me or uh
mad at me and Elon said that about John
McNeil for example who was president of
Tesla it's in the book I talked to John
McNeil a long time and he says uh you
know Elon just would fire people be
really rough on people he didn't have
the empathy for the people in front of
him and Elon says yeah that's right and
John McNeil couldn't fire people he
cared more about pleasing the people in
front of him than pleasing the entire
Enterprise or getting things done being
over endowed with a desire to please
people can make you less tough of a
manager and uh that doesn't mean there
aren't great people who are over in
doubt Ben Franklin over endowed with the
desire to please people the worst
criticism of him from John Adams and
others was that he was insinuating which
kind of meant he was always trying to
get people to like him uh but that
turned out to be a good thing when they
can't figure out the big state little
State issue at the Constitutional
Convention when they can't figure out
the Treaty of Paris whatever it is he
brings people together
and that is his superpower so to get
back to the lessons you asked and you
know the first was harness your demons
the second is to know your strengths and
your superpower my superpower is
definitely not being a tough manager
after running CNN for a while I said
okay I think I've proven I don't really
enjoy this or know how to do this well
uh you know do I have other talents yeah
I think out of the talent to observe
people really closely
to write about it in a straight but I
hope interesting narrative style that's
a power it's totally different from
running an organization it took me until
three years of running CNN that I
realized I'm not cut to be an executive
in a really
High intense
situations Elon Musk is cut to be an
executive in highly intense situation so
much so that when things get less
intense when they actually are making
enough cars and
Rockets are going up and Landing
he thinks of something else so he can
Surge and have more intensity he's
addicted to intensity
um
and that's his superpower which is a lot
greater than the superpower of being a
good Observer